In Belgium, the US vice president meets with top European Union politicians...
...on options for security and aid to Ukraine and steeper economic sanctions on Russia.
In Taiwan, the Aviation Safety Council says both engines of the crashed TransAsia flight...
...failed to provide thrust to propellers.
In Mexico, families of the 43 missing students who are feared dead...
...march for justice in Chilpancingo.
In Greece, anti-austerity protesters gather in Athens...
...to voice their anger over the ECB and EU position on Greece's economic plans.
And finally from Jordan, thousands gather to express solidarity and support...
...for the slain pilot Mouath al-Kasaesbeh killed by the Islamic State.